so man pleasure to meet you this is
this is wow this story is amazing and
it's it's based like daimler is based on
a real character i'm not not a character
a real life person
she is yes correct carlos
so can you tell me about
what it is about this story that was
important to you i it's been a long time
in the making this right it's taken like
over a decade to get this to screen
oh yeah
uh well yeah
evan evan and i have been friends
i think close to 20 years now and it's
been
amazing to see him grow as a filmmaker i
mean he came from you know doing a a
documentary about better luck tomorrow
to doing music videos to documentaries
and
and him you know exploring this world as
his first narrative
you know it was a privilege to be you
know there with a friend and go on a
journey and then also also explore
something that
you know i think kind of paralleled his
exploration with
you know where he fitted in into the
community um not only as a filmmaker but
as someone in the community you know as
an asian american
and i think these issues you know
recently had become so prevalent you
know the timing
couldn't have been any better you know
you kind of wonder what when you're
making these indie films why
the journey is so arduous and so long
you know but then
every film has its own fate and somehow
the timing worked out so
um
yeah so it's been a great journey carlos
yeah you know he has he has said that
you have to love
making it like you have to love making
the film the art of it the process of it
and he seems to take a lot of
responsibility in terms of telling
stories from his point of view from an
asian-american point of view um
now there's this opportunity and all
this attention on people who are now
able to tell stories from their point of
view and be able to be heard and seen do
you feel that that's a responsibility
that you have as well
well
you know i think that's up to the person
i think it's unfair to
put your criteria and your principles
and your purpose behind
um
your work as an artist onto someone else
you know but you know what a wonderful
time as an artist to use this medium of
film storytelling
to
you know ask certain questions to
provoke
certain dialogue so
i think it's up to the person you know
and i think you know we we champion
you know films that you know provoke
these questions and and challenge the
status quo and
make people uncomfortable as they're
watching it right but hopefully
make a contribution to find some type of
an answer to make things better you know
carlos
i got to talk about
choi chang's work on this
she's incredibly powerful
like every frame that you see her on
screen and the two of you share a lot of
um a lot of moments contentious moments
what was it like
being together and actually watching her
um
throughout this whole process
you know she was uh
she was everyone's hero when someone
talks about a lead of a film you know
it's not just the number on the call
sheet it's about
how
uh
you know they are the quarterback of the
energy that happens throughout the day
the level of commitment to her work as
an actress
you know it sets a certain tone as a
lead and it
resonates on screen you see
you know her commitment and her passion
to the work her
connection to the the emotion that this
person you know might have gone through
um and
you know there's a lot of you know kind
of i guess
you know sacrifice and
you know transparency it's very brave of
her to just like exhibit and be you know
put everything on the table like that so
she set the tone you know and like you
said carlos it's you know her work is
riveting you know it's it's great to
watch her on screen
yeah
when you were doing um
better look tomorrow like 20 years ago
could you forecast kind of the spot
where you'd be at now where you're
producing films but you're also part of
these massive franchises one of which
you were a major fan of when you were
young as well
well that's the whole the i guess the
adventure and
you know the the hollywood dream if you
will you know that you get to partake in
things that you were fans of you know
when you get to see
and work with your heroes um that you
grew up with you know like me working
with someone like kurt russell come on
you got to pinch yourself you know you
go what like this dude
like taught me swagger he inspired me
and taught me what like a
self-deprecating alpha male could be you
know it's like you know and then you get
to work with these heroes and they turn
out to be
you know opposite of what you hear it's
like you hear so many times you know
it's it's bad to meet your heroes but
then you meet them and you go yeah man
this is why they're a movie star you
know that's this is why they're beloved
so
you know who who would have known carlos
i can't say i couldn't have predicted
all of this this is all a blessing you
know every day i wake up and i
i go how did i get here you know and so
it makes you just uh you
work harder and be a better person
you know hopefully this doesn't go away
tomorrow you know so
yeah
do you think
that will
what like what are the chances
that will get
a han spin-off
that will get your own like
international man of mystery
snacking in every scene
like
this is this is the movie i want
to change
well thank you i mean
carlos it's because of
statements like that and that type of
energy that i even came back for fast
nine so
you know the great thing about universal
and the fast franchise and ben and
justin and the director um
they listened to the fans you can tell
that
it's a fan made
base fan supported franchise you know
like we wouldn't be here
without the fans and ideas like that
carlos so
hey man if if the people want it and and
the right story can be told and we're
not just doing it for a gimmick you know
we're not just trying to you know cash
in and make some quick bucks to actually
tell a cool story i would love that you
know i would love you know doing the han
spin-off where we go into like rated r
world like wolverine you know what i
mean that'd be cool
yeah
yeah listen
and i mean you could produce it like you
can make it happen
yes i agree we put it out there it could
happen but i agree i mean you never know
i mean it's something that with all
kidding aside i would love to be a part
of and
um you know there's always conversations
about where the world can go so you
never know carlos you know yeah
and as far as working on uh star wars
goes how do you put aside your like
the fanboy part of you
that's unsaid going whoa i can't believe
that this is happening and how do you
snap into the motive like okay we gotta
make sure
that i live up to everything that i ever
dreamed this could be
um
[Music]
it's pretty easy because i feel like
i've had a lot of preparation you know
like i was the kid that would run home
and put on the cheap plastic star wars
halloween costumes and play pretend with
my friends after school you know so
um
you know this was part of my childhood
and my pop culture dna and then
being on sets and being in the world of
star wars and being around all of these
especially other
dreamers if you will that used to play
pretend or imagine if they could be part
of the star wars universe that energy
alone carlos is like crazy right like
you sit there and you go dude like
you're around you you feel
like all of a sudden you found your
tribe because you thought you were the
crazy person and you tell this story to
other people yeah i used to do that too
man i used to make my own costumes and
stuff dude you know it was like this was
my thing you know and
um and then to be able to actually play
a character within that universe with
like serious actors you know like i mean
you got people that have won and have
been nominated for oscars that
come to this playground of star wars and
we all play together man and it's like
as an actor you feel like oh man you
know like look what look how far i've
come like and look at the people that
i'm getting to work with right but then
the fanboy you look around and you're
like you better watch out because i
might be stealing some props pretty soon
yeah
we'll have to we'll have to do this
again and see your uh star wars prop
collection and see what you ended up
jacking from that set yeah man thank you
so much for the time
thank you carlos i appreciate it
congratulations on everything snakehead
is awesomely powerful man and i can't
wait to see uh what else is next thank
you have a good one
you